so far we have described how data store
uses indexes to execute queries now is
the time to look at some query
restrictions that exist as you know by
now datastore was designed to be
massively scalable therefore the
performance of queries should only
depend on the size of the result set in
other words the amount of data returned
in the query and not on the overall
amount of data stored in datastore to
meet this objective data store always
uses two indexes to find a matching data
and this leads to two restrictions you
should be aware of when you design your
application the first one is an equality
filter can be applied to it most one
property within a query the following
filter is not valid because we are
applying an equality filter for two
different properties the second rule is
that a property with an equality filter
must be sorted first the following query
is for example not valid since the
property max attendees is used with an
inequality filter it must be the first
property after sort by not named the
best way to avoid these restrictions is
to think and plan which queries you need
you're in the design phase that way you
can design around them so now we'll do
an exercise where you will explore these
query restrictions